also in the thing that she's been doing
and what doulas will advocate for is you
as the the pregnant person as a pregnant
woman create a team and your team will
include your doctor and your doula
hello pregnant person and non-pregnant
person
I'm Dave Rubin this is the Reuben report
it's June 28 2023. we're live streaming
on Rumble YouTube and locals if you want
to join us for the post game show
[Music]
reubenreport.locals.com you can ask me
questions you can add commentary you can
criticize me you can say nice things
about me you can vent about your own
personal problems whatever you want to
do we're there for you
reubenreport.locals.com and of course
we've got an IOS app and an Android app
where you could do it on your desktop if
you are old school and we're shifting a
little bit away from race horse politics
today I don't think I'm gonna have to
say DeSantis once today I don't think
I'm gonna have to say Trump once today I
don't think I'm saying Biden today
although I just said all of them but
that's not what the show is about today
uh you know the last week or so we've
been talking a bunch about out vaccines
and censorship last Friday of course I
had Dr Jay bhattacharya and Dr Brett
Weinstein on the show to discuss this
brouhaha that happened between Dr Peter
Hotes pro-vaccination Dr Peter hotez and
Joe Rogan and then how that was all
related to RFK going on Joe Rogan and
who's allowed to talk to who and what
platforms these conversations should be
on and a whole bunch more and all of
that and that whole kerfuffle led to an
old video from about seven years ago of
Robert De Niro on NBC when he put out or
was going to put out a documentary on
vaccinations and the risks related to
vaccinations and what happened to him
and that started going around viral
yesterday so we're going to talk about
that connected to now what's going on
with RFK how that's related to Big Tech
how the machine Slanders and then
sensors anyone who dare question the
narrative then we'll connect back to the
hunter Biden situation oh and just
before we started the show today it's
very exciting Joe Biden the elderly man
pretending to be president he was giving
a impromptu interview to reporters
outside the White House and he said that
Putin
just said it maybe we can get the video
that we can throw on the post game uh he
said that Putin is losing the war in
Iraq
so fear not everybody
Putin is losing the war in Iraq there
you go all right let's talk about Birch
gold and then we'll get to it guys uh
you know Congress once again allowed
itself to be pushed into appeasing the
administration and raising the debt
ceiling for the 79th time that's a lot
of times Paving the way for continued
Reckless spending and the further
devaluation of the dollar as our
national debt continues to Skyrocket how
are you protecting your savings Times
Like These are a great reminder to
diversify a portion of your savings into
gold and you can do that with Birch gold
and here's the easiest way to do it
Birch gold to help you convert an
existing Ira or 401K into an IRA in Gold
you don't pay a penny out of pocket and
you know as bricks that's Brazil Russia
India China and South Africa band
together against the dollar more and
more central banks are diversifying you
know what they're buying
you got it gold follow their lead visit
birchgold.com Dave for your free info
kit on gold there's no obligation just
information with an A plus rating with
the Better Business Bureau and thousands
of happy customers Birch gold can help
you protect your savings too visit
birchgold.com Dave take action today
okay let's jump into the time warp
everybody uh we're throwing back to a
video from about seven years ago this is
2016 actor and producer and uh really I
would say uh nut bag Lefty uh Robert De
Niro funded a documentary that he was
debuting at Tribeca film festival in New
York which is his Film Festival actually
uh and the documentary was called
unvaxxed and one of the things they
talked about in unvaxed was vaccine
injuries so he went on NBC morning show
to promote it we're going to show you
two clips from that and you'll see how
we're linking it to everything from
today but here is Robert De hero better
known as Jack Burns from Meet the
Parents uh on the Today Show talking
about vaccine injuries
it's the result of it's not about it's
not questioning how people some people
got autism how the vaccines are
dangerous if not given a dangerous to
certain people who are more susceptible
and they don't nobody seems to want to
address that or they say they've
addressed it and it's a closed issue but
it doesn't seem to be because there are
many people who will come out and say no
I saw my kid change like overnight I saw
what happened and I should have done
something and I didn't
so there's more to this than than meets
the eye believe is that is that the
experience you had Robert something
changed overnight it my wife says that I
don't remember but there was I my child
is autistic and every kid is different
but there is something there there's
something there that people aren't
addressing and for me to get so upset
here today on the Today show with you
guys means there's something there
that's all I wanted was the movie to be
seen people can make their own judgment
but you must see it and other there are
other films other things that also just
document and show you know it's not such
a simple thing okay so that was the
video that was going viral yesterday
because it's interesting because De Niro
who is a far far Lefty I mean Trump
derangement syndrome all that stuff
there he is just seven years ago
questioning vaccines and you can see
actually although I generally don't have
a lot of nice things to say about him I
mean he's been in some some great movies
okay uh but in terms of politics it's
like he's actually being pretty hands
off he's saying hey we created this doc
you should look at it make some
decisions on your own talk to your
doctor every child is different etc etc
but you can see he's there 2016 this is
obviously before Kobe he's going against
the narrative right because you're not
supposed to ever question vaccines or
the Mercury or the other additives that
are in these standard vaccines or the
vaccine schedule that they give to
newborns or anything else so he did get
a little pushback moments later on The
Today Show do you believe you'll now
have a role in that conversation going
forward yes because the thing is that to
shut it down there's no reason to if
you're a scientist let's see let's hear
it everybody doesn't seem to want to
hear much about it it's shut down and
you guys are the ones that should be the
investigating do the investigating I
think the film was controversial because
people felt that the filmmaker had been
discredited even he I'm not so sure
about at the end of the day even him
Jane one thing um it wasn't it wasn't
there weren't sponsors or donors that
were threatening to pull out a film
festival it was our filmmakers okay so
they start pushing back and uh yes the
film then did get pulled first we'll
show you a headline from The New York
Times because he was defending it at
first so New York Times Robert De Niro
defends screening of anti-vaccine film
at Tribeca film festival and you know
how this whole thing operates you defend
it you say oh can we ask questions could
you the media look into it a little bit
more sciences and subtle things like
that and then of course from the
guardian just Days Later Robert De Niro
pulls anti-vaccination film from Tribeca
Film Festival now does this all seem
very familiar of course it does because
this is exactly what we are now seeing
in 2023 with the constant push to
de-platform say Joe Rogan from Spotify
because he talks about some questions
some covid stuff let's say or if I talk
about coveted stuff on this show we
either get demonetized or de-boosted in
the algorithm everything else RFK Jr who
had his interview with Jordan Peterson
taken down off YouTube taken down
altogether started his Rumble Channel a
couple days ago so you can see these
same problems these are just sort of
rinse and repeat problems I do want to
say one other thing about Robert De Niro
is he is a man of science let's not
forget that in Meet the Parents he
turned to Greg focker right and he said
I have nipples Greg can you milk me so
he was way ahead on all of this stuff
which now pretty much every dude with
nipples can milk somebody
anyway about two months after the movie
gets pulled uh here's a headline from
Vox
Robert De Niro and now you'll see where
we're going with all these people and
RFK Jr have joined forces to push
vaccine nonsense their Washington press
conference today is assigned the
anti-vaxxers are emboldened and Vox for
those of you that don't know Vox is Vox
still going Vox was funded to the
hundreds of millions they have done
unbelievably awful hit pieces on me and
many other people and just dishonest
Progressive dribble but you see the
narrative that we're forming there so
the guy puts out a a documentary I'm
just asking some questions about this
you know my son had this problem let's
discuss signs let's see make some
decisions on your own they push back a
little bit try to discredit him he tries
to defend next thing you know movie's
gone he's with Jay RFK Jr who's a lawyer
on some of these things and we got to go
after both of those guys and then this
will get us to everything else but real
quick let's talk about manscaped guys
you know I've got a question what's more
American than a bald eagle Fourth of
July is almost here and that means a
couple of things barbecues pool parties
and last but not least glizzlies and it
just so happens that the sponsors of
today's show manscaped are making sure
all of the Glizzy Gladiators Across the
Nation are groomed for battle on
America's birthday from sea to shining
sea join over 8 million pube Patriots
worldwide who trust manscaped with this
exclusive offer just for you twenty
percent off and free worldwide shipping
with our code Dave at manscape.com talk
about an American Dream it's only right
to start with America's favorite the
performance package 4.0 inside this
package you'll find their lawnmower 4.0
trimmer weed whacker ear and nose hair
trimmer crop preserver ball deodorant
crop reviver toner performance boxer
briefs and a travel bag to hold your
goodies manscaped even threw in two free
gifts in their performance package 4.0
anti-chafing boxers and the shed travel
level bag bring your crotch Comfort to
another level take your freedom bells to
the next level by going to manscape.com
and get 20 off with free shipping using
our discount code Dave get your
Independence back this Independence Day
and unlock your confidence with
manscapes that was one of the ballsiest
ad reads I've ever done all right let's
see where else we're continuing where
else we're going with this thing so what
brings the why why did this video and
all that go viral over the last couple
days well it's all because of what
happened about a week and a half ago as
I said when this Dr Peter Hotes this
vaccine pushing doctor was pissed off
that Joe Rogan sat down with RFK Jr now
RFK Jr's been making the rounds we
showed you a couple Clips yesterday of
him uh with Bill Maher
I want to show you one more right now
this is the two of them talking about
the biased slanderous coverage of RFK Jr
and his campaign that the media has been
dumping all over him over the last
couple weeks
what's my next no you know what
them I just want to say I'm I'm doing
this for a reason one because I think
they deserve richly to be mocked for
that for that attitude I just do not
like the attitude and this gets back to
what you said when you first sat down
there like Liberals are different than
we were kids these are not our
grandfather's liberals you know I I
think Liberals are still liberals but
whatever for whatever reason woke became
the word I know it's not always blah
blah blah but that's the word people use
now for left gone too far and left just
changed their attitude in very in a lot
of ways they're the opposite of liberals
I mean liberalism was about let's have a
colorblind Society
okay so what they were covering there
and why Bill had the newspapers they
were going through some of the stories
that they've been hitting RFK on and
what nonsense it is and how it's coming
out of the purported liberal side and of
course yes bill is Right wok and liberal
have nothing to do with each other and
you guys get all of that stuff so Bill I
love you but I gotta nudge you a little
bit here this is why to call yourself a
liberal at this point when the ship has
sailed an RFK is dealing with the same
version of all of that it's the liberals
who now censor it's the liberals who
don't let you question science it's the
liberals who want mandates and all of
that stuff okay you get it uh now let's
go to a headline uh from Newsweek uh
related to this hotels guy and what
happened here doctor that Joe Rogan
challenged to debate RFK Junior uh sorry
doctor that Joe Rogan challenged to
debate calls RFK Jr shirtless Putin so
Hotes is going after RFK Jr check out
this picture of RFK Jr because this is
the picture they were going after so
this is just a couple days ago I think
this is at his house somewhere in uh
Southern Cali and RFK Jr who is 70 years
old uh look at looking pretty Putin like
pretty jacked right there uh there's a
lot of questions people are saying okay
he must be taking testosterone or
something else or whatever I think
that's besides the point uh you know the
guy obviously is doing something
seemingly for his health and even if he
looked like even if he looked like
this hote's guy who doesn't look so
great that is somewhat irrelevant to
whether the facts that you're talking
about and the way you analyze the data
and the stats and the numbers on Cove it
is legit
or not right speaking of legit or not
here's a fun little compilation we found
of Peter Hotes talking vaccines and
their efficacy uh during the course of
covid it's usually at 10 to 25 here time
frame people forget how long it really
takes to develop an effective and safe
vaccine and do all the adequate clinical
testing I think the current record for
developing a vaccine from start to
licensure in the United States is around
three or four years so that's the
realistic time frame we have to start
thinking about when you look at the
timelines of coronavirus fact this
covid-19 vaccines it really follows the
same progression as almost any other
vaccine the vaccine development cycle
for covid-19 vaccines very much goes
along with what we've seen before and
there are some very variances but but
modest and I think that's an important
story for people to know if they're
concerned about taking covid-19 vaccines
guys guys it's about 10 to 15 years to
figure this out oh uh it's actually
about three to four years to figure this
out oh uh we just did warp speed and
let's pretty much go along with that it
was all nonsense from these people all
along on top of the fact that the
vaccine is not a vaccine a vaccine
actually stops the virus this thing was
never a vaccine and in many cases we're
finding out vaccinated people were
catching covid even more and the vaccine
injuries and everything else and I've
mentioned to you guys I've mentioned
this to you guys before but just one
little piece out of my own life and
everyone has these stories you've got
them yourself I was at a family birthday
party in New York back in October late
October ever there were about 200 people
there everybody basically got coveted
there except for me and as far as I know
I'm the only unvaxxed my parents got it
my siblings who were younger than me got
it Aunts Uncles cousins everybody I'm
the oldest of my generation somehow
everybody got it except Dave so Dave
should be studied Dave should be taken
aboard the mothership and studied
Peter Hotes though this guy I mean he's
just turned out to be a fraud and we
don't have to make it really about him
but he represents as Brett Weinstein
said on the show on Friday it's like you
don't really want to focus just on this
guy because there were a million
versions of this guy this NPC
non-playable character person who was
just going along with whatever the
machine wanted all along right but
hotels what really lit this thing on
fire was that suddenly this guy who had
appeared twice on Joe Rogan to go on Joe
Rogan's show and say whatever he wanted
during covet about vaccines with little
to no pushback which I don't blame Rogan
for I mean Rogan is not a scientist
right he's interviewing someone that's
supposed to be an expert which is why he
then said okay let's do a debate on this
so I can find out more information but
what lit this thing on fire was then
hotels after he after Rogan as RFK on
wants Spotify to boot him even though he
had been on the show twice this was that
original tweet
Spotify has stopped even sort of trying
to stem Joe Rogan's vaccine
misinformation it's really true Anna
Merlin just awful and from all the
online attacks I'm receiving after this
absurd podcast it's clear many actually
believe this nonsense I want to make
note quickly guys that you know there
were suddenly a burst of all of these
articles about how you know these
scientists should not debate Talking
Heads and they shouldn't debate people
on Joe Rogan and they shouldn't come on
shows like this and all that you may
remember on our show on Friday I asked
Jay bhattacharya Stanford a physician
Jay bhattacharya and Brett Weinstein
evolutionary biologist if they would
debate hotas they are certainly
qualified well enough to debate him to
talk about these issues uh he then I've
tweeted that video at him he has now
shut off his replies on Twitter so he
doesn't even want to hear any pushback
so that's just that's just standard 101
you get it they lie about stuff then
they try to silence you they shut off
their replies there's many versions of
what they can do on all of this but what
is the bigger picture here because it's
not just about vaccines right it's
they've lied to us about so many things
right they've lied to us about elections
they've lied to us about who's racist
and they've lied to us about gender and
all of the stuff then this story came
out yesterday this is from The
post-millennial Meta so this is the
parent company of Facebook now meta
promotes former CIA agent to head of
election policies after spearheading
2020 misinformation team
is there a better example that I could
possibly ever show you we could do the
show for the next 50 years I could
literally be 97 years old we will be
doing this show from from most likely a
mental institution actually and I will
be trying to tell you people that that
was the best example of democrat
privilege ever this guy who worked at
meta to deal with misinformation even
though they have been the spreaders and
the amplifiers the hyper amplifiers
through algorithms of misinformation
maybe more than anybody right maybe
Facebook just by the sheer numbers
there's more people on Facebook than
Twitter let's say uh they have spread
more misinformation than anybody they
stop people from questioning things
about the vaccine and covet and
elections and everything else and then
what happens this guy is going to now be
in charge of their election stuff for
this upcoming election
do you think something weird's going on
here uh let's flash back once again
today's a big flashback show let's flash
back to all the way back four years ago
uh this is a Mark Zuckerberg greatest
hit uh when he was on The Joe Rogan
program confirming uh that the FBI
actually did come to Facebook and they
pushed him to censor the hunter Biden
story
how do you guys handle things when
they're a big news item that's
controversial like there was a lot of
attention on Twitter during the election
because of the hunter Biden laptop story
yeah so you guys censored that as well
so we took a different path than Twitter
um I mean basically the background here
is the FBI I think basically came to us
some some folks on our team it was like
hey
um just so you know like you should be
on high alert there was we we thought
there was a lot of Russian propaganda in
the 2016 election we have it on notice
that basically there's about to be some
kind of dump of of um uh that's similar
to that so just be vigil guys guys FBI
is going to show up some stuff might
happen so be vigilant right and what you
have to understand is as I always tell
you guys this is a mafia move that the
FBI put out there they did not say as
assuming that what Zuckerberg said there
is true they didn't come to Facebook
offices and say you can't put any of
this stuff up or ban all of these people
or anything else but they basically had
something's coming and you better watch
out right you better look out and that's
the ultimate Mafia move when the mafia
walks into a restaurant because they owe
him some money and they say well this is
an awfully nice Pizza Joint that you got
here it would be shame if something
happened to it and then three weeks
later it burns down so you you
understand the move that they are making
here now now Zuckerberg also that's not
to excuse Zuckerberg because now not
only do we know that the hunter Biden
laptop story was real and by the way
plenty of people did plenty of free
thinking people knew it why did I not
fall for it go back to all of our videos
when this thing was happening before the
the before the last election and I
always was saying I was saying I don't
know exactly exactly what's on it but
sounds like something's there and the
fact that they're going so far out of
the way to hide it the fact that Twitter
itself pre-elon Twitter was hiding it
not only the links they wouldn't let you
link to it they suspended the New York
posts account but then you couldn't
privately message direct message is what
there is what you privately message with
someone on Twitter privately nothing's
private they wouldn't even let you
privately send the link to people so
there was a massive move to censor
people and you can see this is connected
to what we started with vaccines it's
connected to elections now it's
connected to this Hunter Biden story and
the question is how does the machine
always stay in front of everybody well
every now and again things kind of get
pushed out there enough and this is
largely because of you guys because of
people online that keep talking about
things and then eventually even the
corporate press has to roughly respond
to things in an honest way here is CBS
that's right CBS actually reporting on
the hunter Biden Crime Story I think
this is yesterday
if this was any other person they like
would have already served their sentence
Gary shapley was a lead IRS supervisory
agent in operation Sportsman the
investigation into Hunter Biden shapley
said he uncovered conduct that warranted
more serious charges there were personal
expenses that were taken as business
expenses prostitutes sex club
memberships hotel rooms for purported
drug dealers how much did Hunter Biden
Owen taxes so from 2014 to 2019 it was
2.2 million dollars the back taxes were
paid off and last week the Trump
appointed U.S attorney in Delaware David
Weiss reached an agreement with Hunter
Biden the president's son would admit to
a firearm charge and plead guilty for
his failure to pay taxes if a judge
signs off the deal means no jail time
okay so I want to give CBS a little
credit for actually airing anything
related to this talking to The
Whistleblower asking him his story so
that that is worth noting of course now
there's a couple things here first off
the fact that this guy owed 2.2 million
in taxes over these couple years again
what was his job and how did he get this
job he was a drug and sex addict who was
smoking crack out of carpet with a bunch
of what seemingly now our underage
prostitutes will probably find out more
on that and he had a job at a Ukrainian
Energy company for 83 Grand a month who
having no experience in that field so
who paid off the money where did the 2.2
million come from how much more did he
have beyond that there's there's so many
other questions here but yes they did
let him off the hook with the federal
tax evasion in essence again Ask Wesley
Snipes what he thinks about that Greg
price who's a journalist had an
interesting tweet about or it's a meme
really about this this is how the news
cycle goes it's not happening it's a
right-wing conspiracy theory it might be
happening it is happening in and it's
good and then you just rinse and repeat
I thought that was a pretty sort of
perfect version of the circular lunacy
that we're dealing with with all of this
but let's continue with circular lunacy
because it's important to just not
forget how we ended up in this position
and the people
that took us on this Joyride to Hell one
of those people is White House former
White House Press Secretary Jen saki who
is now of course a uh television host on
the televised mental institution known
as MSNBC here she is when she was press
secretary back in 2021 uh explaining to
us that the hunter Biden laptop which we
now know was real and a bunch of us
thought it was real all along uh here
she is telling the media that it's
Russian disinformation
the president has said and you have
tweeted that allegations of wrongdoing
based on files pulled from Hunter
Biden's laptop are Russian
disinformation there is a new book my
political reporter that finds some of
the files on there are genuine is the
White House still going with Russian
disinformation I think it's broadly
known and widely known Peter that there
was a broad range of Russian
disinformation back in 2020. man
everything they say it was broadly known
and widely known though it turned out to
be completely real
when Trump was President you guys were
allowed to say relentlessly that Russia
meddled with the election when Biden
came into office suddenly you couldn't
question anything 51 former intelligence
officials signed this letter that
basically said that the Biden laptop the
hunter Biden laptop was Russian
disinformation and no it turned out not
to be it turned out not to be uh Hunter
Biden you might be going well Dave how's
Hunter Biden doing these days he got off
he got off he also got off the charges
uh he was how's he doing these days well
just a couple days ago he was at a White
House dinner because they do invite a
lot of former crack addicts and
prostitute people to these things the
White House was honoring Indian Prime
Minister Modi uh and just days after he
uh signed this sweetheart deal he was
over there here's Jen sahi now MSNBC
television host Jen saki uh saying that
Hunter Biden going to this dinner you
know crack addict criminal blah blah
blah it's what is it you can guess
already it's an act of love Joe Biden
loves the crack addict
so Jen saki I'm just curious because if
you look at right wing websites or watch
certain certain TV channels
um you will hear all about Hunter at the
state dinner I mean you will hear Jim
Jordan going on and on and on about
conspiracy theories and and you won't
hear as much about this and I'm just
curious the White House obviously not
going to chime in on these audio tapes
or anything like that but at the same
time how does
how does the the Biden White House make
a distinction that cuts through to
people that are being honestly misled
such a good question Mickey I don't
spend too much time on right-wing
websites but I can completely concur
with what you're saying about what's out
there and the challenge the White House
has right now we saw with Hunter
appearing at the state dinner was in my
suspicion was the president his son
wanted to come so his son's going to
come to the dinner was that optically
easier for the White House and the White
House communications team absolutely not
but I said family circumstance of him
wanting to come and wanting to just the
president wanting to show that he loves
his son and he's standing by him guys
try to imagine if Donald Trump Jr while
Trump was president was caught smoking
crack underage prostitutes all of the
porn accounts the illegal business
dealings all of the that we
basically know right and then two days
later the first off he just gets slapped
on the wrist with some federal charges
and then they're just going to let him
skate by and everything and then Trump
has him show up to a dinner these same
people these fraudster propaganda
Candice these Pravda level propagandists
would be saying this is him flouting it
in our faces and this should lead to
impeachment because it shows you he put
pressure on the Department of Justice to
make sure his son got off and everything
but what's it about because of democrat
privilege he loves his son
he loves his son and by the way his son
also you know he sells art and art uh is
one of the easiest ways to money launder
in the history of the world right
because art is completely subjective in
value so a crack addict with the
prostitute sitting on his lap scribbles
out a little something I'm Hunter Biden
we're gonna sell this thing for two
million bucks and then someone gives
Hunter Biden 2 million bucks and then
next thing you know you've got access to
Joe Biden this is how money laundering
has worked in terms of politicians and
influence Peddlers forever but it's an
act of love because they're Democrats
and it's not just we played it the other
day who was it Claire mccaskill former
Senator Claire mccaskill she said it was
the ultimate Act of love Joe Biden
defending his son saki it's an act of
love and unfortunately we do have to
show you a clip of one of the ladies on
The View
and it's an active well it's not an act
of love coming for me but it's an act of
love from well you got it Go the hunter
Biden story
the Scandal the this that it's also the
story of a Father's Love and Joe Biden
has never and will never give up on his
son son Hunter and will never treat him
lesser than and so he is a father first
take it or leave he's a father first
he's a father first this is the same
father who told us repeatedly that he's
never discussed business dealings with
his son what a great dad he's got a son
the son's got some problems obviously
crack addict whatever son's working at a
Ukrainian Energy company his dad is vice
president was pressuring to get a
Ukrainian prosecutor fired like there's
a whole bunch of stuff there they never
talked about it he's such a great father
and he loves his son so much he never
said Son what do you do for a living by
the way are you are you working for uh
never did that never did that the point
of today's show guys is to show you that
everything they do is designed to make
regular sane people think that they're
crazy that is what they are doing to us
they are trying to Gaslight us all into
thinking that they're right about
everything and we're wrong about
everything and we can only question
things when they want us to question
them and if we Dare Challenge The
Narrative we're going to be labeled what
they used to do to Trump what they're
now doing to RFK Jr what they do uh all
the reasons why you and your own
personal life probably don't say all the
things that you think you should say or
that you believe because that they keep
everyone in this non-stop state of fear
and the only way to defeat that I would
say there are two reasons and they're
they're deeply connected you can defeat
that with truth and you can defeat that
with humor and that's why the best humor
is taking something true and getting as
close to that point where someone can
laugh where they're not going to punch
you so I thought we would end in this
video is going around and today was the
big throwback show it was the Reuben
report throwback banana uh this is from
a couple years ago Norm Macdonald one of
our greatest modern comedians who
unfortunately passed away about two
years ago who I just loved Norm met him
a couple times
um here he is a couple years ago talking
about this new woke term cisgender and
the point guys again you just have to be
able to laugh at their nonsense
do you know that that you are a CIS male
have you ever heard of that term
CIS male
c-y-s-m-a-l-a so what it means is that
you are a man you're born a man well as
far as you know as far as I know and you
identify yourself as a man yes that's a
CIS male no I don't understand where is
that is this a new phrase yes it's a way
of marginalizing a normal person
so you're an assistant man
this other person's a Tran so you're
equal she she's a man that thinks she's
a woman you're a man that thinks you're
a man
yes everyone is is
self-identifying
guys the point is it's all ridiculous we
can use their language we can try to
just respond to them or what do I always
say we can build no thing new things we
can fight back effectively we can
separate from them we can elect better
politicians and adjust at the end of the
day it's all
uh
that has been the Reuben report
throwback show for today June 28 2023 if
you have not subscribed already please
do at rumble.com Reuben report we've got
a live post game show coming up for you
in 30 30 let's say 36 seconds 36 seconds
at Ruben report.locals.com we leave you
uh with the elderly man pretending to be
president I like this one I just gave
away too much but you'll you'll dig this
one and I'll see you guys on the other
side ciao
thank you
so the best way to get something done if
you if you hold near and dear to you
that you uh
um like to be able to
anyway
[Music]